hey everybody good afternoon it's Mike
it's uh February 4th already and uh it's
four o'clock in the afternoon 44 sorry
February 4th at 4M um I also want to
thank everybody for taking the time to
come out uh today to catch this uh quick
presentation on the orderflows algo you
know this is uh this is a a tool that we
released back in November and you know
I've been getting a lot of uh positive
feedback from it and um Trader's been
wanting me to do another presentation on
it and actually uh for the users of the
software we got a special training
coming out on uh on I think it's going
to be Friday of this coming week so um
you know for those of you that that
don't yet have it and have been
interested in it you know I I want to
sort of go over what it is and uh you
know how to use it because it's the oldf
flows algo right it's a tool
that you know it took us some time to to
develop
because I I needed a tool that would
help Traders understand supply and
demand you know we always talk about
supply and demand and how to use it with
order flow and it's not as simple
as you would hope right me we all we all
use the term supply and demand we also
use the terms uh support and resistance
sometimes people use them
interchangeably supply and demand and
support and resistance when it's really
uh two different things and when we
created the orderflows algo we designed
it to run on normal Candlestick charts
it can run on a footprint chart but in
all honesty you don't need to run it on
a footprint chart um because it it takes
all that analysis that you would have to
do on a footprint chart and basically
puts it on the normal Candlestick chart
for you so it just you know makes your
life a bit simpler in that respect
effect okay um and to be honest if
you're depending on the type of
footprint chart that you are using you
know nowadays um there's a lot of an
extra analysis that goes on with
Footprints right with value areas um
stacked imbalances uh zones being drawn
out and again you know if you're using a
footprint chart and you're drawing out
things like stacked imbalances uh then
you got spy and demand zones being drawn
out it can be kind of confusing because
it's going to get messy is going you're
going to have a lot of zones overlapping
each other
and I'm not going to say you're going to
get tuned out of them but you know
sometimes you have a lot of zones going
on that are overlapping and you're just
like ah you know what's the point of
having them right and keeping it on a
you know on a simple
uh bar chart in my opinion just makes
life so much easier for the Trader you
know it's it's much easier to identify
things that are happening
in supply and demand on a normal bar
chart okay that's just my own uh two
cents on that but we'll discuss it you
know we'll take a look at charts uh
shortly and uh go from
there
so when Traders try to Define supply and
demand it often comes very late in the
sense that they're simply looking at a
chart and determing it afterwards right
and you know there there's the saying
hindsight is 2020 and it's no more trer
in trading than in anything else I I see
a lot of people posting charts
up then just marking them up afterwards
oh yeah there's it's clear there was
supply and demand here or there was a
resistance Zone here or this or that um
after the fact
and the other thing that you're going to
run into is identifying supply and
demand consistently and technically not
subjectively because sometimes you ask
Traders right you get a room of 10
traders to and you give them the same
chart a you know determine supply and
demand on this chart okay well the most
obvious ones are going to draw the high
and the low um but you know the in
between areas um it's going to be
different between the 10 Traders okay so
once you need to be able to subjectively
draw it over and over and over right
based off of a set of rules um and again
the order flows outgo based on supply
and demand but mixed in with order flow
um that's not going to change right it
it's fixed you know that's the one nice
thing about having to
program uh the way you look at the
market when you have to put it into a
program right you have to program
it is binary right zeros and ones and
you can't take that
subjectivity that you would have just by
looking at a chart and today that's you
consider this a a supply and demand Zone
and then tomorrow you know you you
wouldn't right I mean that that's not
how you should be approaching the market
right you have to have a objective
way not subjective way of identifying
supply and demand okay but then once you
do identify it what's the next
step well you need to confirm it right
that yeah this is supply and demand okay
and again you could have something that
looks like supply and demand you know
Supply Zone being formed or demand Zone
being formed then it it
fails okay then people just erase it off
the chart like it never existed well it
did exist initially on on the way you
were looking at the chart you know it
just market conditions changed you know
there wasn't that
um confirmation so to speak that hey you
know what this was a supply or demand
Zone okay
and S of the third part is is you know
once it's confirmed right you need
signals once the supply and demand zone
is confirmed and you know just really
quick to show you how it looks on a
chart right if you're looking at a
normal chart so this is I don't know
what this is e- minis from Friday right
the 2 um you know as nonfarm payroll
Dave Market had a nice
rally and then people are going to draw
out supply and demand zones oh yeah you
know this was the low you know obviously
there's a demand Zone here you know
there was a supply Zone up here okay you
know the most obvious ones um but
there's a lot of trading going on
between the high and the low of the day
because you know what at one point this
wasn't the high of the day right this
was the high of the
day okay and you know at one point this
day but that doesn't mean that there's
no other supply and demand zones coming
in during the trading day right supply
and demand is what moves the markets in
a basic sense you I always say you know
order flow moves the markets well yeah
what's order flow what is order
flow well order flow is the supply and
demand that Traders
have that's coming into the
markets okay it's just reflected in the
volume that's
trading so you know don't think that um
for a second that supply and demand's
got nothing to do with order flow it
it's highly related to order flow right
because how the orders are flowing in
and being traded in the market is a
direct result of supply and demand how
much demand there is at a
level right or how much Supply there is
at a level right demand if you're
looking for the market to go up you need
demand in the market right and with
orderflow we often talk about the
aggressiveness of Traders right the
aggressive buying the aggressive selling
you know people lifting the offers or
hitting the bids people selling at the
market or buying at the
market but you know know if you
understand order flow it's not just
aggressive trading that's taking place
in the market you also have passive
trading passive buyers coming into the
market people bidding up the market or
people offering it down not necessarily
lifting the offers to take it up higher
they're providing support in the market
by not only buying the offers but
working strong bids bids that are
supporting the market just as if a
market is dropping right they're going
to be offering out Supply they're going
to be not just selling the bid to help
move the market down that's what's going
to move the market down but what's going
to keep it from going back up what's
going to keep it from going back up is
that Supply in the market right that
that's the
inventory that's there of you know
available contracts or people that have
it on in their trading book so to speak
right the the the prop traders that are
holding snps or you know holding bonds
um that's their inventory then again
think about it in everyday sense right
if you've ever run a business whether
it's selling stuff on eBay or Amazon or
Etsy or actual having a physical store
right like you're selling stuff um you
know you have inventory the inventory is
your supply your customers provide the
Demand right they're going to buy your
supply from you and you know often times
you going the stores will run sales they
will lower their price right they're
passive sellers looking to draw in the
aggressive buyers right the whole
concept of um auction market theory is
that relationship of supply and demand
you know how it's moving it's constantly
moving right if supply and demand was
evenly met the market wasn't wouldn't
move right it would stay at one
price but we know the Market's not like
that and especially uh the way the
markets are now they're they're
constantly fluctuating right and it's
because the supply and demand Dynamics
are changing all right now when you get
into into sort of the
market we call it Market mechanics
Market
fundamentals the whole concept of supply
and demand is a whole another level
right we can't tie it down to one thing
right there's so many um things that
drive the market right you got um macro
Traders Traders at hedge funds right
taking long-term views you got real
money buying and selling the individual
uh stocks that are underlying in the S&P
500 or you know trading in the actual
bonds right a bond trading desk or
actually trading currencies you know
it's all that stuff that makes up the
supply and demand okay but that's not
what this is about it's about the thing
is all
that all those people have to come to
the market they have to come to the
Futures Market the CME Group and trade
that on the screen so their transactions
will show up on the screen hence the
order flow okay so if you're looking at
a chart right the easiest way is you're
going to identify spy demand is is
basically is oh yeah there's demand down
here at the low of the day duh right
there's Supply up here at the high of
the day yeah duh but what about
everywhere in between you need a way to
consistently identify it because there
are areas between the high and the low
where there is demand where there is
Supply in the market because if you're
just going to say oh there was Supply
here then sorry demand down here at the
low yeah you'd be right but does that
mean there's no Demand on the way up
does that mean that there's no Supply
coming in at the way up to arrest these
moves there probably is but you need to
be able to identify it and with a set of
rules and consistently okay that's why
we came up with the orderflow algo to
identify that you know on the chart to
draw out these zones now you you'll
notice there's sort of different
intensities of these zones some are a
little bit darker than
others
and blue for bullish red for
bearish you can see these lighter color
zones like this one this one this one
the market had traded back into so are
the darker ones the market hasn't yet
traded back into okay so it hasn't been
um you know retested so
like that's why they light color blue is
because it has been tested and failed
okay and again you know supply and
demand zones aren't absolute in the
sense that the market is going to always
stop and turn at them you know often
times they will right you can see down
here at the low up here at the
high okay and again you know people will
say well there was Supply coming in here
right Market dropped from 49 um 85 20
points down to
okay you could always make that argument
but you know based off of the orful algo
it's not saying that there was Supply
here they say there was some Supply here
and then demand here then demand came in
again here demand came in here demand
came in here okay but again drawing them
on the
chart honestly it I one of the biggest
problems I have with trading tools is
oftentimes or even even
traders that Mark up their charts right
they're looking at a chart like
this this is you know taken after the
market had closed oh yeah there was
Supply up here demand down here
um you know maybe you had a demand in
here or something they're drawing it
well after the fact what you need to be
doing or have something that's doing for
you is drawing it as soon as it appears
now it's not going to appear oftentimes
right on the
bar on the low of the day or the bar on
the high of the day I wish right but to
be honest you're not going to determine
Supply based off of you know this is a
30 second chart you're not going to base
it off a 30 second
bar you know it's you can't right there
there's got to be more to it that's why
oftentimes you see these um on the algo
right it's drawing it out right and it's
you see the market pulls back in here um
but it's not confirmed yet right
and I see tools out there and I'll show
you one later um where they they draw
out supply and demand zones but
oftentimes what they don't tell you and
I've seen them make videos on this after
the fact and it just irks me is they'll
say oh yeah there was a demand Zone down
here at the at the
low okay and but their Zone often
doesn't print until the Market's well
away from there right and what what good
is it if yeah there's demand here but
it's not telling you till it's 20 points
away right what you
need is a tool that's that's going to
actually draw the arrows telling you hey
there's demand coming in here right or
Supply coming in right that's what the
arrows signify right and again honestly
I wish there was a a easier
way that would tell you soon as this bar
prints right here 932 buy it because
that's a demand Zone but you're not
going to get that off of a the
information in 30 seconds right this is
a 30 second bar
um you know here it took a few minutes
it's coming in closer and this is again
one of the problems that because I've
tried all honestly you know I'm friends
with a lot of other vendors that sell
tools and stuff and you often times they
give me stuff to to try out give me
their give for me to give them give them
my feedback on things and it's like okay
you got a supply and demand tool but
it's not drawing
in it's sort of it's being a little bit
disingenuous in the sense that yeah I've
got got demand coming in you know like
here you got demand Zone being drawn but
by the time it signals it's a little bit
far away right is it going to be more
effective as a one as opposed to one
that sort of pulls back in there okay so
that's just some of the things again
there a 30C chart but I'm going to show
you later with using something like a
fivem minute chart or even a 15 minute
chart um how to Zone it you know how to
get closer in because you know when
you're looking at supply and demand
obviously the sooner you can get in the
better in my opinion so we created the
order flow algo to address these issues
right identify supply and demand
consistently and technically not
subjectively where can change based on
who looks at the
chart or maybe how you look at the chart
even you know sometimes you may look at
a
chart the first time and not notice
something and then like you like later
say oh oh yeah that's so obvious it was
there well let the software do it for
you you need to confirm that supply and
demand right give you that clear
signal
of there is supply and demand here okay
so again the order algo is fundamentally
based on supply and
demand but then we couple it with the
orderflow okay so again it removes that
step of having to look at a footprint
chart and by removing the need to look
at the footprint chart it removes the
need um to have a messy chart I no one
likes to have a messy
chart now
orderflow does not require tick replay
sorry the orderflow is algo does not
require tick replay um to run on a chart
it can run on a chart with tick replay
though if you like um but I know some
people say you know tick replay really
slows down um their system for whatever
reason you know so I know some people
got older machines um we can't always
upgrade as often as we'd like you know
like even myself I like to upgrade my
PCS
um and but really what I when I do that
I I look for sales right because you
know
pric you know prices always go up and
down Black Friday is always a good time
you know companies have sales in the
summer Black Friday in July Amazon
always got Prime days Etc but you could
run it with tick replay but um you don't
necessarily need to use tick replac
because if you're using a you know a
normal for example if you know if you're
using normal bar chart right you know
you're not going to slow it down by
using tick replay tick replay is
something you would use um
with Whatchamacallit with a footprint
chart okay you don't really want to run
a a normal bar chart with uh tick
replay okay so that's uh sort of one of
the benefits that's something that again
you know a lot of
people have uh issues with but I just
going to skip over this part because
this deals with if you actually have it
right
the license part
um because if you have the order flows
algo you do need a license for it but uh
well let's take a look at it in action
or we'll start with the settings first
okay so people can understand sort of
what goes into the order flows algo okay
so there's
zones there's supplementary zones as
well as regular zones
okay supplementary zones are extra
supply and demand zones that are
generally seen in Trends as opposed to
more traditional supply and demand zones
being generated at swing highs and swing
lows I have it disabled by default okay
because you don't necessarily need um to
see it on your charts okay but you know
some people would like to see it and
I'll show you some charts in a second
here let me just uh pull
up let me just pull up a chart here real
quick okay so like this is Mees okay now
there there's all sorts of different
settings that you can do rather than
using
the the thing uh I'll just show you
through really quick right here okay so
let me just get my crosshairs go up here
make it a little bit stronger um to see
crosshairs got to set at two but I'll
set it at three so it's a little bit
easier to see what I'm talking
about Okay
so recall our pullbacks right that's why
you know some of these zones are dark
red because these zones haven't been
traded back into right this is a darker
blue this is also a darker blue these
are Light blues these light blue ones
have been traded back into okay this
dark red ones haven't been traded back
into yet right this one got within a
tick
here this one hasn't been traded back
into okay that's why there's different
colors in case you were wondering
um and supplementary we call it
supplementary pullbacks deals with
supplementary zones now there's
different types of strength okay and for
most Traders we're going to focus on
normal trading
um there's you could follow a minias
chart or a longer term chart but normal
trading is fine for most Traders and
there's different strengths that you can
use for your supply and demand one is
the base level right that's what the
default is and again you could go up
to you know 30 or or 50 if you wanted to
um but all in all honesty the higher you
go obviously the more strength it's
going to be the less signals you're
going to see if you just you know 1 to
two it's a minimal change but obviously
from 1 to three it's a little bit
stronger change so again this is three
right it's set at three now and you can
see okay there's a few less signals
coming in in here right as opposed to
one right there was um you know there
was more coming in here but at three
right you don't have some coming in here
now again you can experiment on the
market that you're trading right this is
two um you know levels I like again 135
7 this is
five it's giving you the major
here you know it's giving you the major
moves here right from here all the way
up to here then you get the bearish one
okay and again you know maybe you want
to see more of the trading
day this is it this is uh set
at five um you know seven is going to be
slightly less signals okay this is here
set at
seven um you know if if you want to
go I don't
know I mean 10
or you know if you can go to a very high
number like 20 that's a strong one right
now you're just getting the major ones
okay and again if you're using something
like say longer time frame
trading strength you just keep at one
because it's take into account that it's
you know a much longer um time frame you
can see there's just
the signal from way back here the day
before before you had that big runup so
again if you're like a swing Trader or
something maybe You' use that um longer
time frame trading okay
um if
you're going to use like say um yeah I
know some Traders don't like to use time
based charts they want to use
um
a whoops a range based chart or even a
volume based chart but uh let's just go
to say
A you know 10
range um you'd have to work out the
settings for that market
okay so like this is s you know on a on
a 10 range chart obviously during um the
evening sessions it's going to be a
little bit choppy right like you see
here this is from you know the reopen at
5: until the morning 8 this is 9 o'clock
here this is on the
reopen um Friday Thursday evening into
Friday morning right then had some nice
moves so again it it's depending on the
chart that type that you're using it's
it's flexible right obviously you will
have to make some adjustments um you
know this is a the one minute chart here
okay it's a little bit cleaner than a
range base charts but again you know
people use all sorts of different charts
um you people use time based charts use
range based charts everyone trades
different markets right I mean if you're
looking at crude oil whoops you know
market like crude
CL
okay you know this is with that setting
that I was just using on um e mini set
the seven you know maybe you don't want
to have it so strong you know maybe you
want to have it a little bit weaker you
know you set it at five or something one
the base setting which is I believe the
default setting is going to be you're
going get a lot of signals okay which
maybe um
you know you don't want to see it's just
one of those things where you know it
can be a bit overwhelming for some
people even though the general Trend
right you see a lot of Supply coming in
here you're sort of missing the yeah
little demand here little demand coming
in right
and I just want
to show you something okay um there is
there are other tools
for supply and demand okay from you know
other other places right and they
they'll show you things like this right
a chart like
this okay and you think hey this is
great right it's all short but there are
times
where okay well let me take
off supply and
demand sorry take off the algo first and
you think oh this is it this is the Holy
Grail
but what do you notice about this chart
okay just go back here you're thinking
there's never any
demand well there is demand that was in
here like because you only see the
demand coming in down here you're
thinking oh this is perfect I just got
get this as the holy grail and I see
this with a lot of indicators is
there I don't know what the term is I
don't want to say redrawing it's more
like they're they're erasing the demand
zones that were here
that we're here all on the way down
because if you're thinking for a second
there's no demand zones coming in here
there are you get any of these things
that don't that just like take them out
after it's been traded through the
reason these are still here is because
they haven't been traded through yet
they traded into right traded into here
traded into here just hasn't traded
through yet right
because you know this looks like oh this
is the greatest thing since sliced bread
but there's not there's demand zones
coming in here in here is just not being
drawn out right that and that's the
important thing that
was where the
algo right that's you know sort of the
difference between the orderflow algo
and you know a lot of these other tools
is we
don't mislead you into thinking that
there was no uh demand zones down here
or here or here or here so why we still
draw out these zones right but and again
the valid
ones the ones that are confirmed are the
ones that have the blue up triangle for
buy the red down triangle for
sell and again you know depending on
this is a crude this is a one minute
chart depending on how you're trading
right whether you're a scalper or you
know a bit of a longer term Trader um
it's going to depend on how you
approach the market in your risk
management so again this is like a this
is a fivem minute chart and again if
you're on a FIV minute chart this looks
messy you what what the Mike
well it's because you have the algo set
you know kind of
low they go strength because now you're
on a five minute chart so you want
something a little bit stronger right be
seven right
and you know now it's giving you some
nice clean signals that are coming and
being confirmed a few moments after the
high of the day has been made right
which is what you like to
see okay so let's U let's go through
here so that was the some of these zones
right oh
the
max spine demand Min and Max okay that's
an important setting because you know
with
zones there's different intensities of
zones okay and and that's where again a
lot of Traders sort of Overlook right
when they're looking at zones okay
because here you'll notice right this
zone is quite big or then this one is
quite big it goes from
7393 down to 7370 so that's a 23 um tick
zone right and sometimes the bigger the
zone that you're getting the longer it
takes for the confirmation to come in
okay as opposed to sort of the smaller
zones this is coming in a few bars later
okay so let's just go back
to
well
whoops go back to Ms as I know I got a
lot of mes guys in here so you can see
here right here's a strong
Zone from 91 and 3/4 down
to 20 what is that 25 and 3/4 actually
on here we have a
setting move it up
here where you could actually draw the
Zone height how tall it
is okay but here the Max and Min so you
want a
Zone that's at least two price levels
strong right because in slow times based
off of orderflow often times you're
going to get
you going get not tricked but just
because of the way the market is trading
because it's a slow
time
um a supply or demand Zone drawn off of
one price level okay and you probably
don't want that um and for some Traders
you know they want something where it
takes in you know the zone is going to
be a little bit stronger right so for
example if I said it at five it's got to
be covering five um minimum of five
price levels right so you can see here
earlier in the night when the market was
in a tight
range right just let me open this up
here go back here because during the
trading day it's not much of an issue
but if you're trading at night
okay notice right you got I set it to a
lower the lower level right
two right there's quite a bit of zones
there's you know here here here here you
know here Etc but with
a setting a Little Bit Stronger say
five right you're not getting as many
right and I'll say it's the stronger
zones but it's zones that are taken into
you know that do take into account a bit
more of um order flow going into the
supply and demand Zone and
again you could draw out here so you can
see how big these zones are 24 25 you
know 13
12 and in some cases right in some
markets like M andq that that's a bit
volatile you you know because the bars
are so
wide you're going to have zones that are
over 50 price
levels which is not really what you want
to do right it's just too W it's just
too much vol is too much I say it's not
what you want to do is because you don't
want to take in all that extra risk in
setting your stops right because you can
see down here under draw text The Zone
end is your stop price The Zone start
price is where you would add
on okay so you know if I set this at a
higher number
50 Max it's going you know these zones
are 24 13 they'll still show but you
might get some zones that are um you
know quite big this Zone was
29 there's 29 ticks between here and
here so from
4977 down to the bottom of the Zone 4977
is the top of the Zone 69 3/4 is the
Bott you're risking 25
ticks right and you can see some of
these zones this one's 35 this one's 27
this one's 24
[Music]
um snps have been
rallying I don't know if there's any
big big
uh Supply
zones that were there not really
everything is
just S&P is just a lot of demand coming
in right now
um but like for example NASDAQ
right this is M andq
okay
what do I got here this is a 30 second
chart if I set this at 50 right you see
at 25 there's only two
signals again grant that it's a 30
second chart but if I set it to
50 there'll be more right that's just
the nature of it and
again you don't want to take in too much
right because again that's going to
affect your risk to reward ratio because
you know I see people you know I see
Traders you know for example just really
quick
here right they
they'll draw a chart oh yeah there's
Supply in here get short okay only they
telling you to get short at at
4980 let the stop at you know above the
supply Zone at
5,000 really really want to risk 20 full
points 80
ticks I I I just don't think it's it's
it's worth it in that
sense
see this one's nothing yet
uh let's see
here M and
Q well what I would have to do actually
I think is change that so set of 50
normal trading I'll set it down
to
down to
one see what it comes up so we seeing
more signals you know some big doesn't
look like much but these are Big zones
because it's m
andq right I don't have it turned on but
it's turn it on and see how big these
zones are
here it's 47 ticks 30
ticks um again if I'm on a 30 second
chart if I was on a minute based chart
probably look a little bit different
slightly bigger zones but again on a 20
if I have the zon set
to
25 instead of 50 all these that are over
25 31 37
47 um you know they're not going to
appear right
30 again mq is a unique Market in that
sense where um it's just a bit more
volatile
than um the other markets okay so anyway
back here
to uh Mees okay so let's take a look
again here at the rest of these settings
now the orderflow analysis you could
choose to enable
it or disable it okay and let's just go
here through the
settings default is
enabled so when
enabled takes the order analysis into
account range from 1 to five it can't be
zero can't be over five
one is the
strongest three is normal which is sort
of
average setting of five is the most Li
liberal okay so again three is average
one is the strongest now you can use
settings of two and four okay
but again you
know if I wanted to I could have just
made at one two three with one you know
and two being average and and five but
you know we were sort of looking at the
uh at the results and it's just like oh
I'll just keep them in there but let's
see what
the well here well first we'll remove it
okay and you could sort of see
there's going to be well it's set pretty
high but uh I'll set
it I'll change this back to
uh 25 and we'll set this back to two
and you'll see right orderful analysis
is disabled
okay you can see there's a lot of
signals okay
when I enable it okay I'll start with
the strongest form of orderflow
analysis it's going to
remove signals right it's going to
remove some of the supply and demand
Zone
were is not being there okay so all you
see is just mostly the blues going up
you see one red here so basically from
this move
from the open or you know this was Cash
open here at
8:30 early in the morning there was some
Supply that came in but really the rest
of the
day there's one spot here around 11:
where some Supply came in again around
1:00 in the afternoon here and here
then later the supply was coming in
honestly you're at your high of the day
late in the
day after the market you know went up
from you know 4930 to to 50 basically
here a lot of buying a lot of demand you
late in the day you should just you know
everyone Friday afternoon is probably
long got a lot of Supply on their books
and they're going to start offering it
out up here I'm not surprised to get
late in the day to see that Supply come
in um later
now one is sort of the the strongest
they said five is going to be the most
liberal so you're going to see a bit
more signals now people are going to ask
well hey can you tell me what goes into
the orderflow algo well no um I'm not
going to tell you exactly how it's
calculated because you know I do know a
a lot of people out
there will go out there and copy it okay
um and sometimes
it it
uh it bothers me in the sense like you
just buy the indicator we did all the
work already so you see it's the most
liberal here at five so you seen
remember on the way up before you just
had a couple instances of Supply coming
into the market but now based on the
order flow a liberal analysis of the
order flow you're seeing a bit more
Supply and actually a bit more demand
and coming in on the way up
so again if you're adding the order
flow you know you could keep it at one
or three I I prefer three that's sort of
I don't want to say it's an average but
that's the that that's the level that I
think is
uh most conducive for most
markets you know and some people I know
some people like to be more strict you
know they want to keep keep it um you
know the strongest again it's up to you
uh what you want to do now again there's
some settings in here you don't need to
worry
about I already explained the Zone end
price
in um in ticks and Etc so again I like
to use
three as my spine demand strength
setting that's the strength value the
order full analysis back at three don't
need to keep it so strong now when we
talk about
pullbacks
okay you can see here there's some
settings draw text Zone end price is the
stop Price Zone height just tells you
how many ticks the height is but the
add-ons right Zone start price so you
can see here okay there's a Zone being
drawn
here
4953 so if you're long off of this
Zone where's your stop going to be it's
going to be 40 just below 4953 it's just
draws tells you the price right so you
don't have to I mean you could move your
cursor over it but it's just easier to
draw the price write the price there so
any Zone you know the lower level of a
blue zone is basically your your stop
price
um on a red one right the top price is
going to be there now we have what we
call the add-ons right because adding on
to a
position is something that you know a
winning position is something you always
really want to
do okay so example right if
you're long like down here this Zone
down here at the
low okay this blue arrow you could see
might be a little hard to see but
there's a blue arrow here so it's
telling you this zone is
confirmed okay and we're trading back in
the zone so anywhere between the high of
the zone at this point now it's already
printed
4925 49
29.5 to 29 and 25 and 3/4 that's your
add-on area right so you just drop in a
bit another bid in there to get long
anytime it tests it just as um let's go
back
here excuse me right you have a Zone
being drawn here comes in here to the
top of this Zone that's where you're
going to add on just as if you were you
know you had a Zone here could always
get short you know on a pullback knowing
that at the other end of the zone is
going to be where your stop is right and
you still need to have stops right you
can't trade without stops um because
there's going to be time stimes where
Market keeps pulling back and it it
keeps pull back right I mean you can't
live by the whole concept of buy the
dip without realizing that the dip could
keep dipping right or sell the rally
with the rally keep
rallying um okay so going through these
these other settings you don't need to
worry about things like data series that
just tells what the chart is ETC um I
just want to burn through that I covered
all the already um you can choose what
color you want to draw the zones out
blue red you know blue for buy red for
sell some people I know like to use
green for
buys and then the plots right how it's
going to plot the arrows triangle up or
triangle down rather um blue for buy
signals that's the confirmation right
that is uh confirmation of taking the
trade right I this is e minis if I was
say I was looking at bonds
whoops right that's this red triangle
here sell sell sell sell sell and this
is Bonds on Friday again it's a one
minute chart again people use all sorts
of different charts you
know if you're using a you could use a
range based chart you can use you know
I like to use range-based
charts but again you got to if you're
using a range based chart I think you
need to adjust your settings a bit
more um because the way the chart is
formed right now it's not formed on
time it's formed based off of price
movements and that can change the way
supply and demand is
calculated so you can see here looks a
little bit different color-wise okay but
you're still catching obviously the
major Trend down the day before it's
just all demand all day long again this
is when the number came out
here right you get the sell signal
coming at 732 but even though it looks
like there's a lot of movement between
here this is a range based chart this is
non-farm payrolls right this is after
nonfarm payrolls here this is the rest
of the day where it's just been
basically short
all day
long and the day before was long all day
long um again you know whether you're
using time based
charts I don't even know what it's going
to look like on a tick based chart I
mean tick base I don't use tick base
charts
on interest rates I don't even know
where to start
but know
that's a 100 tick I don't know
200 tick
chart setting if You' want to use seven
maybe you could use
this when trying to determine you know
based on the market you're looking at
what is the best strength values so you
start at one go one 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 nine
10 but or you can just go 1 three five
s because again sort of the differences
between one and two two or three
are you know I don't say minuscule
they're small but they're you
know move from one to three is going to
be a bit better so this is you know a
setting of
three you know you want to use a setting
of
five okay maybe you want to use you know
stricter order flow analysis of
one okay so again it can vary you know
how you want
to
how you want to set it up right for the
market that you're trading now there's
some
markets I don't want to say there's some
markets that follow supply and demand
better but because that's more of my
opinion I haven't been able to
actually do like the hardcore analysis
on it and say it follows it better but
think about it for a second right
markets like commodity markets and um
I'm sort
of how to describe it partial to
commodity markets because that's where I
spent a lot of my time in my career
right I worked for Cargill and when I
worked for JP Morgan and I worked for
EDF man you know EDF man is the English
Trading Company commodity trading
company he's been around since the 1700
I worked at Cargill um and I was hired
at JP Morgan to help set the commodity
business in Singapore
so I'm really partial to Commodities in
the sense
that I I I know that I don't say I know
them better because obviously at JP
Morgan we're trading everything
um
but people that trade Commodities sort
of have to right they have a reason to
trade the commodity because they're
probably a producer or supplier or
somebody that needs the commodity for
their own purposes right they're they're
making soap or something right and they
need palm oil you know you'd be
surprised if you look at the back of a
bar of soap a shampoo all the there's
actually you know palm oil palm oleon
you know things like that all go into it
cooking oil is a big thing um things
like soy meal okay people say wow soy
meal what the hell Michael um but Soy
meal is a market that you know it's one
of those markets that people trade sort
of because they have to like that's
their business and sometimes seeing how
supply and demand Works in those markets
now again there's an overnight Market
but you know the day session from you
know when it re closes at 7:45 reopens
at 8:30 that's the old us session I
guess you would call
it um you know so 8:30 you see just all
Supply that day on Friday day before you
know a little bit different you had some
Supply early demand midday demand again
late
again I'm not surprised to see demand
coming in at these lows uh the day
before right there's the reopen sort of
nothing then theand starts coming in it
starts rallying like a banshee um you
know so some of these sometimes these
Commodities you know copper I mean we
talk about gold
but you know
copper is a market that Trends nicely
oftentimes doesn't look like it on this
chart but you can see demand sorry
Supply Supply Supply every time you get
these little spikes up strong Supply
coming in Supply Supply and there's
demand there's
demand people always ask me what about
Nat gas look I want to trade Nat gas I
don't know why um people would want to
trade n gas but you can um because again
that's it's a bit volatile I me it's
winter time right now but I do sort of
think there are better times to trade it
I mean so you probably want to have a
stronger strength on a market that
is um you know a bit
volatile you can see some days are
better than others but again net gas is
not something that everyone
um it's going to want to trade about
Forex right Euro currency 6E people
always ask oh what about can I trade
Forex
well can you could trade this is
eurocurrency right this is the number
right this non-farm payrolls coming out
here and you can see the supply coming
in right ahead of that here here now I'm
not saying that yeah you could have sold
it here and and sold it from 109 all the
way down to basically
108 later in the day but you know I I'm
the type of person numbers coming out
like this a big number I'm just going to
stand on the sidelines um but obviously
late in the day you get some nice nice
moves and you can see what was
interesting
where did the market stop on Friday
right we're going to reopen soon um but
where did the market stop on Friday it
stopped down here now you know people
say well 108 even is a big psychological
number blah blah blah but this
was a demand Zone from the day
before right here
right you know you can even see right on
the day before here Supply
Supply then late in the day we had all
that volatility come in trade back up to
the previous Supply Zone here even here
got back up in
there
okay
um you know the markets British
pound British Pond kind of similar the
demand Zone there the demand Zone there
you know before the number came out they
give off a buy but again I don't
Advocate ever trading right ahead of an
major
release um jaff
Yen similar
thing kicking off your supply zones
Supply up
here Demand right where did this Market
come back and basically paused before
the number came out paus about three in
the morning two in the morning until the
number came out then it broke through it
but this was a big demand Zone from the
day
before right it came in here it didn't
stop at the low of the day right because
again you know the most obvious supply
and demand zones are going to be the
previous High and the previous low this
is sort of the middle of the range right
came back in
here okay
um sort of go through the slide deck
really quick there's some settings you
don't need to touch like the setup that
just basically tells you what it's
looking at don't need to worry about
those again the up and down triangles
you can change the colors these plots
are more for if you're using something
like markers um that's why you need the
plots let going to automate the so again
using the orderflow algo really this the
settings that you need to worry
about there's not a lot of settings not
a lot of moving parts right which is
important because as a Trader you don't
want to be having so many things you got
to adjust really all I focus on I said
four strength value supply and demand
Min and supply and demand Max in
orderflow strength is really just the
strength value I tend to be consistent
on my orderflow
strength either all my charts I'll keep
it at one or three I don't use five
because if I'm using why would I want to
use the most liberal I want to use
orderflow um so I'll use either one or
three but the strength value depending
on the market and the chart type um
chart type I mean time based or range
based or something uh I would start at
one one and sort of go up from there 1 3
5 7 again you could use two you can't
use like 1.75 it'd have to be a whole
numbers like 1 2 3 4 five six seven but
I just keep it simple 1 3 five
7 people oh those are FIB numbers but um
no here so base setting for strength
value is one it can't be zero you can't
have zero strength It's
just sometimes people say well I said it
at zero and it doesn't work well yeah
because it's a setting you need to set
it at a value I like to use 1 two 3 7
and 15 you can go above 15 but I don't
think that's really necessary because
obviously the higher you
go the stronger it's going to be the
less signals and if you're going to go
very high then you probably want to use
a longer time frame change it from
normal trading to a longer time frame
and then just set it to one because if
you're on a longer time frame um just
keep the value set to one you don't not
going to
use a long time frame with a strong
setting just keep the strength setting
at the at one and again the max Min this
is the thinness of the zone or the
thickness if you will um if you're half
uh glass half full glass half empty and
ideally you want to have some zones with
some meat on the bones okay and I'll
just show you really quick here
um let
me I'll change this what do I got here
I'll change it to a
bond
okay and what do I got it set
at
if I think you actually set it at zero
meaning
well any basically well I'll set it at
one so you're going to get some
well hard to tell on this
day oh let me find a a slightly thinner
Market
uh trve fives but I have it set kind of
strong here seven that's why if I set it
to
one with the zone of one but let me
just show you something I'll set that
Max to
five
there's going to be with this strength
value of one right which is about as low
I should probably have set the orderflow
strength um different but I got it at
one anyway but you can see in
here close that
down you see there's some zones this one
is one this one is one this one's one
one some people might like that I like
to use a minimum of
two but again depending on the market
that you're trading if it's a thick I
say a thick Market a market with a lot
of
um volume right that tends to just go
sideways often times you can get away
with one but if you're trading a market
that's a little bit more volatile set it
at two okay um see here right this is
the day before setting at one this zone
is one this zone is one this one is one
this one is one right
which is it may uh not be the most
prudent thing you know if you're trading
something like a euro currency and it's
set at
one you can get again you can get quite
a bit of small signals again this Z is
well this one's two but you can see in
here be some
ones there's a one
here
some ones that got drawn through here
down here these it's not going to show
because they're already traded through
but uh just keep that in mind right
that's that deals with that
um why it's set at two
okay I I wouldn't set it over five
unless you're trading something like M
andq right most markets keep it at
around two now
the
Max right
25 it's fine for most markets but NQ mq
even to certain extent ym you could
adjust it to 50 just because the
Market's going to be a bit more
volatile and Order flow strength
right this one is the
strongest two
is a little bit less strong but stronger
than average three is about average
five is the minimum amount of overflow
needed okay so when using the Overflow
analysis it's going to affect where the
signal is drawn on the chart by a bar or
two or three because again how stronger
you're using the actual order flow to
confirm it is going to tell it's going
to when it prints the up triangle or
down triangle right if you set it
stronger it's going to need more order
flow that's why this the signal actual
up triangle or down triangle may be
drawn at different spots if you're using
different orderflows strengths right if
you're using five it's going to be more
liberal you might get a signal earlier
than if you're using one which is the
strongest okay so let's take a look at
some charts I just got some charts here
this again this is e Minis on Friday
okay this is seven which is quite strong
you see the ill analysis strength is set
at three which is sort of its um the
average strength there okay this is
where it's set at one strength value so
you're seeing a lot more
signals is set at three fewer signals
right and I showed you the seven earlier
okay um these are some charts
from a few months ago back in November I
just had them laying around so I just I
threw them in there this is supply and
demand Min set at two this is set at
four okay just to show you the
difference right I didn't need to go
pull up new charts so you could see here
right set at four it's finding wider
zones minimally in the sense that it's
got to be at least four ticks as opposed
to this is two ticks here right and you
see there's a Zone here that's no longer
there The Zone was here with two but at
four it's gone okay so by setting the
Min A Little Bit
Stronger it's going to find zones that
are a little bit more sturdy right think
of it like ice right the thicker the
ice technically the longer you can stay
on it the thinner ice stay on thin ice
eventually it's going to break pretty
soon and I like to think of that with
supply and demand okay now this is set
at 10 okay so this is
four but set at 10 it's finding these
very big thick zones only here
here does that necessarily mean they're
stronger and they're better well this
one worked out nicely this one worked
out nicely got a nice pull back in here
nice pull back here this one it pulled
back it failed okay one pulled back and
failed this one failed you had three
small fails here but one really nice big
winner 30 points you know this one is
about you know again if you're buying on
the pullback here at 80
81 let's move up to
91 you know can you again people always
want something that's 100%
accurate 100% of the
time but I want you to realize right
there are times when you're buying a
pullback sometimes the market keeps
pulling back you buy this pullback here
Market keeps pulling back buy the dip
right you've seen those crypto Traders
always say buy the dip then the market
keeps
dipping you buy the dip here it's a nice
winner buy the dip here it's a nice
winner that's why knowing having the
zones drawn out gives you a visual
representation of where where to place
your stop okay well I know that if I get
past this
lower part of the blue that's where I'm
going to be
out right just say here it get stopped
out fine it get stopped out up here fine
it gets stopped out here then know I
could catch a move like
this so this is the orderflow analysis
set at three this is where it's not
turned on this is disabled at this point
so you see most signals are going to
show when you're not using the order
flow analysis right that's again that's
with the Overflow analysis on that's
with it off okay this is set at one it's
a bit stronger three sorry this is five
the most
liberal
okay so basically that's the order flows
I'll go in a nutshell again um this was
really to introduce you to it to get you
familiar with
it um we've got a big user group and
again we're sort of in the process of
setting some further stuff up for the
users of the software uh Friday this
coming Friday for users of the software
we got a special
um special training I guess is that's
the word you call it um to sort to get
more out of you know out of how they're
using the orderflows algo because
there's there's a lot of ways there's
certain um things that I haven't really
I don't want to get into now because
it's more advanced think of it as this
Friday is is a more advanced session for
uh Traders so again if you're interested
in the orderflows algo it's
uh that's the website orderflows
algo.com just pull it in here really
quick on a browser just show you what it
looks like here
www. whoops it
W's
orderflows algo.com
right just this I want to put it in the
chat there I want to get to some
question question shortly guys
um I'll put it in the chat so you watch
this little welcome video and you can
see it explains how the zones are you
know the formation again I don't want to
get into sort of the mechanics of it
because that's not the whole point of
this presentation because I know there's
I will get questions so how's it
actually
calculated yeah I'll be honest I some
people mean well when they ask that they
they do want to know and but I've been
burned um by people say oh how is this
calculated and then later person is
selling something like that very similar
with slightly different name they
they'll add a different name to it
um but again you know people have been
using this are
are very happy with it so you know you
scroll down there you could use PayPal
you could use stripe um you know however
you want but that's the that's the link
right here orderflows algo I'm going
take a I'm going to burn through some
questions here
uh you know quick I don't want to keep
you guys on it's Sunday night and the
market is just reopened I have if I have
this indicator James as if I have this
indicator Buy sell if I have the
initiative Buy sell indicator and
passive Buy sell would this indicator
help
um this is an interesting question J
that's a legitimate question but uh
honestly when I use when I look at
indicators I'm not a what's the word I'm
not the type of person that goes
and loads up all sorts of indicators
because Lord knows I've created my
programmer has created for me a lot of
indicator I have a lot of different ways
of analyzing the orderflow right like
for example right I got the trade
encyclopedia right there's like 130
trade setups in there and I do get
questions from people oh my God I got to
memorize 130 trade setups no you don't
you got to find the ones that work for
you and again you know I've developed a
lot of tools that look at very specific
things in the order flow
and sometimes I thought well I'm just
going to load everything up on my chart
and see what
works and it's not
as simple as that and just leave it at
that um because there's there's so
much things that either work together or
work against in a sense in
orderflow and I
have actually have
uh some of my indicators combine certain
things of different aspects of order
flow to put it together for example like
the combo but generally speaking um what
I tend to focus on is certain aspects of
orderflow at a time rather than trying
to um do it now that that's not to say
that it's not going to work I mean by
all means you could test it out and try
it
um but it's in my opinion it's it may
just based off my own experience with
other tools trying to see what works
with what works with what works with
what doesn't work is sometimes it's like
50/50 sometimes it works sometimes it
doesn't right just because it's you're
trying to take in sort of different
aspects of orderflow all at the same
time when market
conditions aren't necessarily suited for
it um no you can't use and constantly
ask about the Sarah charts um no you
can't use it on Sierra charts um
unfortunately I I had a falling out with
the guy well not falling out I ghosted
um a guy shared a lot of information
with and and tools and you know we had a
nice partnership going and then one day
it just got ended
um let me see here so uh does the Zone
box initiate only when they Arrow yes so
the Zone box only initiate sorry
the let me go back to the chart here
okay so you can see right there's
signals here let me make this
bigger ninja if you got these big on
volatile days get these big bars so for
example here
right the
actual Zone may be drawn out if there's
no confirmation that can happen right
like here the zone is being drawn out no
confirmation there's no up triangle the
ones that have the actual triangle or
zones that are confirmed
okay so there there may be instances
where you have zones being drawn out but
no uh
confirmation I know some traders that
will still trade those me I like to have
that orderful confirmation
um and why would it do that well it was
just maybe just taking too much time for
the order flow to confirm it but we
decided to still keep it on there
um because it did meet the conditions of
supply and demand but really the algo is
supply and demand coupled with order
flow right needs that order flow so
that's where the um triangle is going to
come in but the triangle should come in
right around the time that the zone is
drawn okay because once that once
it's for it to be confirmed right it's
going to it's already doing calculations
for the zone that is telling you it's
there now it's taking into account the
order flow to confirm it okay and if
it's takes too long for the order flow
to confirm it you're still going to have
that zone being drawn out like this one
here okay there's no up Arrow over
here just like this
one but it doesn't mean that just
because the order flow didn't confirm it
it's not support or Supply or demand
just doesn't have the order flow to
confirm it okay and again does that make
it stronger or
weaker
well me being an orderflow guy I like to
have the orderflow confirm it um that's
just me
um PR is there an option to get higher
time frames find into lower time
frame yeah you can I mean so for example
right say you want to do this follow
minute based chart so this is a one
minute chart and
and okay let me just take set that back
to normal um set this back at 25 I don't
know what Market are we looking at here
eurocurrency and so I'm looking at a one
minute time frame but you want to look
at a higher time frame okay so follow
minute based chart so I'm on a one
minute chart
and you know you want to look
at a
60-minute signal on the one minute chart
I just calculating
here the data series turned on this one
it's turned off
so so it's a one minute chart why is
that oh strength value
three again I should keep that
there
to offset in text
second base
chart seems like a bit more
signals than I'd
like again you know Friday was a bit uh
hectic so you can see here right these
are 60 Minute signals on the one minute
chart or what I would just suggest like
just use the longer time
frame it should be in my opinion that's
better here you can't even see it
because such a long time
frame one short there long here again it
depends on how you're going to look at
the market but it's possible
um let me open this up here
okay even take a look I didn't see your
email you know recently problem
with Google and
Yahoo
is the other day it sort of this email
apocalypse thing
where they really made this big effort
to filter out spam emails and
promotional email emails and it's
affected everybody so I'll check because
I think maybe your email actually ended
up in my spam folder because once it
sends one email there from a person all
the rest will go there um because I know
like even my programmer who I've been
email and like every you know every week
for the last 10
years they say my email all a sudden
starting to show up in spam but I'll
take a look there for your license
youan
um if you load more days Christian asked
if you load more days algo will pick up
historic zones that haven't been traded
through so what's the optimal number of
data days that you would suggest to have
the Oro Alo analyze
um well that's a good question because
you know what when when people talk
about supply and demand
okay technically the levels should hold
for a long time right until they get
traded back into so for example okay
let's set this this is uh this
eurocurrency I'll just sort of set it at
normal so like here okay I've got it's
set at how many days not that many um
five I mean if I were to go say 20
days okay you know there might be some
big like here right there's a big
overhead Zone
um coming in there you know from that
was when last month right the
29th
okay so again I mean you can draw this
so you can see like these zones from way
before overhead
zones right they go back quite a bit of
time um
[Music]
even you know beginning of this chart
right from the 17th
Supply zones that haven't been
touched
now it's one again this is a one minute
chart okay so it's not like it's an
hourly chart so you're looking at hourly
zones from a long time ago for me
personally just my own opinion on that
um I like to trade in the
now not necessarily have levels and
again you I'm based off order flow
the orderflow that's taking place now is
based off of what's Happening Now And
even though this is a
level that was
formed it's quite old in the sense you
know for example these areas here from
the 17th so about two weeks ago okay and
it doesn't mean they're not legitimate
zones but what sort of formed those
zones at that time off of the order flow
from whatever
you sell off you know these are zones
one you know one what is that 109 uh 80
more or less or almost 200 points
lower what's going to happen now going
forward right if the order flow all of a
sudden starts changing becomes very
bullish even though I have these zones
up in
here from two weeks ago or by the time
we get up there it could be three weeks
it's one thing to know that they're
there but I I don't necessarily for
me if this Market starts getting a lot
of
demand I'll put
more um belief in that demand that we
have currently than that supply that
happened three weeks
ago okay it's one thing to know and
respect that you have levels up here
okay you can't not I say dismiss it
because it was form for a
reason
but I'm going off of the most recent
activity in the market right the order
flow and so if I see a lot of demand and
it's coming up to these levels
especially if it's taken out Supply
levels all in between you know from here
all the way up to here I'm not too
worried about what's happened up here
three weeks ago because um you know I'd
be looking for the market to take those
out as well honestly if the demand
starts coming in and it's
strong
okay that's just uh my own after how
many bars uh zone is drawn well it's not
a fixed set it depends on how the order
flow is coming
in
um Rob asks Is this different than the
Vault package yeah it reads completely
different uh things in the order flow
all my you know I've Dev
just give you an idea right they got the
trade encyclopedia 130 trade setups I've
got about 30 indicators right
which basically there's so many
different ways that just gives you an
idea how robust orderflow is there's a
lot of different aspects of orderflow
orderflow is just not the buying and
selling in the market it's the
aggressiveness right it's where value uh
where volume comes in how it's traded is
it traded passive and
so every indicator that we release is is
reads different aspects of the order
flow this is different um reads
different parts of the order flow but it
does not only does it read the order
flow but it also does you know the
technical analysis of determining supply
and demand as well
okay
um Chris ask how do you use this algo as
a standalone tool do you use he always
says hey Mike do you use use the algo as
a standalone tool in conjunction with
the footprint to confirm
um I use it predominantly as a stand
alone
tool I will watch it I I have screens
open up I got multiple screens but I've
got charts opened up um you
know uh bar charts opened up on my other
screens and if I see something happening
on the algo like a Zone being drawn out
and it's confirmed I'll look at the
order flow as well right but I know that
if I'm looking here right like for
example here okay I see this is the
reopen here right five o'clock just
reopened
recently you see overhead Zone overhead
Zone see a small bullish Zone here okay
but I know we just run right through it
so I'm seeing some Supply coming in
early on Sunday night um um which to me
is is bearish and I'll watch you know
take a look at the order use it in
conjunction um with orderflow
basically um Erin ask this is
interesting question how would you know
which spine demand zones would give you
a higher probability access in other
words how would you know zones are
stronger than others well
one I hate to use the intensity that
sort of the the how strong a zone is
right like the bigger the Zone because
obviously the bigger the
Zone the more I don't want to say the
more chance it's got to hold but
generally speaking all right it's
like I see guys do this a lot they'll
say oh look at this you got a
big they'll do
this right this is Friday it's hard to
see this bar because this was on the let
me just open up this chart really quick
here where where are we here here right
so here's the bar okay a little bit
bigger
okay actually it's up here be value
Gap well gez yeah and then be like look
and it's holding well no it's
holding it's from
10860 to
what is that 40 50 you know 42
picks the rest of the day by just trade
40 ticks um I
mean so I don't know you know I I I tend
to keep the zones in between two and 25
levels so if it's you know on the upper
end of 20 you know in the 20s I like to
think it's a little bit stronger that
doesn't necessarily mean it has to
hold but really what I sort of one of
the the pet things that I like when I'm
looking at zones is sort of their
proximity to each other so if I
see like a couple of zones coming
in either one right after the other or
two you have a Zone then you have
another Zone with not a lot of space in
between right I like that because what's
that market is telling me that you had
some Supply come in Market sold off
Market came back up to your supply Zone
then you got more Supply coming in um so
to me that those are sort of the zones
that I like um overall so you could
either come in sometimes you're going to
see them let's see here let's go
back normal day here uh let me just get
this chart back to
normal so for
example this was
was
Thursday
Wednesday right there's a Zone here
another Zone close proximity in this
case from
44 and a half of this sorry 84 and a
half up to 86 right or the
ones I don't if I'm going to get any on
this sort of chart where they're
overlapping like this I like to think
those are stronger
um that's just me and but again this is
a one minute chart I like to use smaller
time based charts actually get down to
like 30 seconds even on a lot of markets
but there's there's different ways you
could use it but that's some of the
things I'll be talking about on Friday's
session um sort of the the things that I
use to
uh get the most off of
it
um Carter hang on Carter let me ask see
your note
[Music]
here I'm just writing this
down your email
address I'll get you
those download
links and get them out for you uh Joseph
ask what is the difference between the
algo and the three Vault
indicators
okay I think I pretty much covered that
I said you know
the um the algo right is traditional
supply and demand analysis coupled with
order flow The Vault indicators deal
with
uh actual order
flow and um yes it deals it's only
available Michael on
nt8 it's not available on the other uh
platforms yet nt8 is it's the platform
that I use it's stable um you know it's
it's a it's the fine platform I know you
know some people are partial to Sierra
chart some are partial to other
platforms mod of wave Etc but
uh me and my programmer we
use uh Ninja
Trader all right guys it's coming up on
uh 5:30 I don't want to keep you guys on
too long um so I hope you guys were able
to get some good information get a good
overview of what
the uh orderflows algo is again if
you're interested in it just go to
orderflows algo.com or not orderflow
algo it's
orderflow algo.com all right guys so
I'll let you go and have a great uh rest
of your night it's Sunday night and no
football this weekend oh there the Pro
Bowl you call that football I that's
over already um and uh you know those of
you that do get it up I'll see you guys
on Friday for those of you that have our
regular order flows um software talk to
you guys on Wednesday and Ean and Carter
I'll I'll get your questions addressed
uh privately over email thanks everyone
have a great uh evening and I'll catch
you guys later
bye-bye